حركه المقاومه الاسلاميه حماس مشاركه
السلطه الفلسطينيه في اجتماع شرم الشيخ
الامني اليوم بحضور اسرائيل التي تصعد
عدوانها ضد الشعب الفلسطيني وجددت في بيان
صدر اليوم دعوتها للسلطه الفلسطينيه
للتوقف الفوري عن الانزلاق في مسار
المشاريع الامنيه الخطيره التي تستهدف
مقاومه الشعب الفلسطيني
واكدت حماس مجددا ان هذا المسار لا يخدم
سوى الاحتلال واطاله امده وتحسين صورته
دوليا على حساب الحقوق الفلسطينيه
المشروعه كما دعت حماسه سلطه لوقف كل
اشكال التنسيق الامني مع اسرائيل واجهزه
الامنيه بلا رجعه كما جاء في البيان
كان المؤتمر الشعبي الفلسطيني ومنظمات
شبابيه نظموا وقفه احتجاجيه في غزه رفضا
لاجتماع شرم الشيخ الامني الذي يبحث
التهدئه في الضفه الغربيه وعبر المؤتمر
الشعبي الفلسطيني في بيان عن رفضه اجتماع
شرم الشيخ الامنيه الذي يعقد مع الاحتلال
وبمشاركه السلطه الفلسطينيه دون اجماع
وطني وفقا للبيان
وندى دال البيان بما سماه نهج السلطه
الفلسطينيه الاستسلامي مطالبا بتصعيد كافه
اشكال الاحتجاج كما وصف المؤتمر الشعبي
الفلسطيني المشاركه في الاجتماع بانها
استكمال للمؤامره على المقاومه وعلى خيار
الشعب داعيا لانهاء الانقسام الفلسطيني
والتوحد خلف المقاومه وفقا للبيان
العوده وال